[Music]
welcome everybody my name is RAM
Ramanathan and that means that you've
stolen much from PricewaterhouseCoopers
what we want to spend the next hour or
so talk to you guys about how you can
use machine learning to kind of change
common retail processes have you ever
wondered how we can enable cost
customers to find the most relevant in
the right product at the right time how
you can enable them search easier than
just doing the dated textual query like
people are more and more visual how do
we enable them to search better and it's
really what we wanted to spend some time
or the next hour we're talking about how
we can apply ml for common scenarios in
retail here is a lovely diagram of
showing how we do a deep learning neural
nets the rest of the session is going to
be talking about convolution neural nets
and spending a lot of time and deep
learning and the goal for it is of
course to find the text with an images a
cat or a dog which is great for my
vision scenario but what am i what does
that have to do with retail in fact that
you can find a cat or a dog it's
interesting I love dogs but doesn't
really help you guys on a day-to-day
basis that's really what we want to do
is spend some time thinking about common
and all scenarios that you can think of
in your customers among your day-to-day
use and how you can apply that we think
of three key scenarios that where
machine learning comes to play one is
enabling your customers or your users to
find the right product at the right time
right how do we take people moving them
away from just regular textual searches
to thinking about finding products more
visually the other aspect is how do we
help them recommend the right product at
the right time or if you really think
about this we want to think the PPD with
more and more as choice and how it
better and the thing is we can help
customers is how do you give them the
right product or right time based on the
apply of the user behavior in the third
piece is once you have released a
product out into the wild how is this
product doing what are people talking
about it what else are they referring to
when they use this product you guys guys
can get a better feeling of sentiment
understanding what they do with the
product and get it better and so that
can then drive your lifecycle small
product development perspective
marketing perspective
and multiple downstream activities so
I'm going to talk about couple trees now
so let's start but why finding the
favorite product how do we do that today
today most retail stores you normally
think about the online web preference
it's normally you have a textual box
they do a product search query you know
and people normally kind of gravitate to
search first part of it is because of
the behavior that they do every day when
you bring up or open up a Chrome browser
and it's searching the tab and they're
kind of guard and indoctrinated to
search first
so in duskiness scenarios how's your
search experience and so far searches
are be mostly textual but one of the
things that we've seen more and more
people are moving more and more to
images and video to kind of communicate
right whether it's um messaging
applications whether people ping their
favorite images on Pinterest on the
favorite social apps or Union if you
think about good scanning through blogs
get inspiration to what they want to
purchase once they do get the
inspiration what do they do with that
they can't really find their product at
the favorite retailer anymore right
because it's an image most probably so
how do we enable those two now how do we
enable your consumers to discover
products easier that's one aspect the
second piece is how do we think about
giving recommending the right product to
the right customer I think one of the
use cases in when we think about Google
and recommendation is you know we have
over a billion hours of video content
watched every day on YouTube we may say
okay what's I got a recommendation the
reason people watch so much video on
YouTube is because they see this related
video tab on the lower right corner but
it's based on your user behavior based
on your product metadata we then serve
up appropriate videos that's relevant
for your context not just the clickbait
meaning that if you watch a cat video
show more cat videos really focus on
what's relevant for that end user and
thinking about time to view and say this
is a video you really want to look at
that's the case of a Content perspective
but you can then translate that to
products on a day to day basis just
because somebody bought something last
year does not mean they're going to buy
something this year because it may be
externalized external teas like
seasonality there may be social events
because one of the favorite teams one of
sports events I'm a dry behavior there
may be other things with that more
internal factors that drive
recommendations on out of stocks etc and
how do you think about taking all of
that to drive
right product recommendation for end
customer and the third piece is I talked
about the sentiment right really
now did you release the product it's out
in the wild people are doing all kinds
of craziness with your product but then
what's going on with a product do people
actually like it right I mean it's funny
enough like I am a frequent customer or
bought Google Shopping and an Amazon I
spent a lot of time reading those
reviews right those reviews clearly
influence what I purchase right and so
thinking about for us a manufacturer or
retailer you will need to understand
what are people saying about this
product out in the world and you really
want to understand what else are they
talking when they talk about this
product what are the other entities who
are the most perceived
substitute in the customers mind what
else do they normally talk about from a
comparative perspective they talk about
your product how can we help you
understand that and that's normally all
that data is not necessarily inside your
organization a lot of data is outside
your organization in social media how do
you then harness all that data to get
insights into your recommendations so
that's really what we're going to spend
the rest of the time about these three
scenarios finding products talking about
recommendations talking about sentiments
and how do we start driving scenarios
here's a quick view of all the different
services that we provide on Google cloud
platform to really think about that and
what I want to spend some time is City
how do we bring these services together
for one or two scenarios from a machine
learning perspective in general there
are two key ways that we provide access
to our two machine learning one is as a
platform place so that's really where we
are clearly going to be talking more
about tensorflow tomorrow where we think
about tensorflow has a number-one open
source machine learning platform but any
of you can build your own models on your
data run it anywhere and then when you
want when you're ready to run it at
scale and a managed environment you
bring it to our cloud and we have cloud
machine learning engine that helps you
really Drive you of your machine
learning models but from a training
perspective or prediction perspective
and that's really targeted at data
scientists and folks you want to really
manage the machine learning lifecycle
from end-to-end perspective at the other
end is really what we talked about
machine learning api's saudis our api is
really focused around
using Google models using Google
infrastructure and providing new
targeted solutions for scenarios for
example or on language and help you do
things like finding named entities when
tities in a block of text or finding
things like sentiment whether it's an
imagery table to be really efficient API
last years how do you find common
entities and in the case of video which
just announced yesterday so really
that's very using Google models to try
to get insight into unstructured data
and we also have other API is like jobs
API will focus on really targeted
vertical use cases like thinking about
job placement and that's really the kind
of portfolio of machine learning
products that we have today from
Google's platform in one and based on
tensor flow with cloud ml engines and
instead of ready to use the api's on the
UML API side and the goal for this talk
is talking about how can we use some of
this technology to drive to go back to
those three scenarios I talked about how
do you find your products easier how do
you help drive recommendations and the
third aspect is how do you help
customers understand sentiment
so let's first focus on the first one
how do you help find the right product
so there are a couple of things and it
scenarios I'm going to focus on is
really Iran searches a search for image
as you can imagine there are lots of
other pieces that you can do from a find
the right product where things are on
search engine optimization they're
thinking about how you can tune your
existing search index and tuning better
using last research but those are in my
mind of the technology already be in the
market for a few years it's kind of a
well understood process of how you think
about search engine optimization how do
you drive searches across your metadata
today people are solutions today so what
I want to spend some time thinking about
is how do we think about finding the
right product and if there are a couple
of things you can go around this thing
one is how do you I've in the user of
your website sends an image as far as
the search box how can I get metadata on
that image
what is that image about so I can drive
search process the other aspect is
thinking about logos how do I Drive is
there any product branding information I
can take to drive certain aspects and
then how do I think about fraud if I'm a
marketplace and different people are
posting sellers and buyers sellers are
posting products the dating garage
itself how do you know the marketplace
on
that this is the right product or not if
somebody just doing a fishing exercise
by the addicting some random stock image
posting on the marketplace is this a
valid image and so we're just going to
talk about a couple of ml techniques
that enable that scenario the first
piece is image metadata this is
something we released last year it
normally works in scenarios is we don't
it really works in more generalized
scenarios so the information you get
back from what we use call a vision API
is more generic I would say higher-level
categorization information is not really
targeted specific information but it can
give you things like it's a leather
handbag and give you the color of the
and bag and I can then drive that can
get you metadata to then drive on
subsequent search the other piece so for
example one of our customers we have
usually they may be enabling a search by
image feature in their in their half
they want to start driving things like a
I want to search for say Brown canvas
back so we can give you the computer
color we'll give your term is a bag and
potentially with the canvas bag and then
you can then drive a search index based
on that within the metadata they've
collected already another piece that we
talked about is using how do you think
about using the web for fraud and
topical entities what that is is if we
just released our new feature called web
detection so that's really the
functionality and the Google image
search so what does that give you is if
an image exists on the web right so it's
just important point if an image exists
on the web we and our web crawler is you
imagine we crawl through billions of
pages on a daily basis we index a lot of
these images we can then find metadata
about that image and feed that back so
when you say when you post an image to
us we can then tell you this metadata on
this image based on cat and on lots of
different pages that we scan it just
means ABC doesn't make sense and we can
also tell you where this image for
similar image exists somewhere else on
the web so that's another aspect that we
provide so really this analogy we think
about is if it's topical entities we're
scenario for example you want to find a
product with a very famous logo we can
pick up that a character like a Marvel
character or a character for my BBC show
that's very popular in the web we most
probably pick up the character from
Tommen
image and the other aspect is also is
for fraudulent scenarios but if you're a
marketplace you want to see are these
people posting fraudulent images on
stock images on my marketplace right so
we all do it all at the bus I'll show
you some examples of that but be careful
about this because some because we use
the web metadata we can get a lot of
false positives too so for example of
this this is clearly a stormtrooper
image but we also give you a metadata
called
pregnancy and you're like why did you
get that so if you click on this link it
actually goes to a Pinterest page and
somebody dares use this image to drive a
baby shower right so and so that's began
to break clearly it's a very popular pin
page and so a lot of pages are linked to
it and that drives our ranking and it's
clearly also on this image of a
stormtrooper helmet it's not late to fix
rings so you just need to think through
it I just want to caution you it's not a
antidote to all problems there it works
well for many scenarios it also doesn't
work for some scenarios so that's that's
a piece that I want to leave you guys
with so let's kind of walk through how
you want to do it can you switch through
them
perfect so in the first thing so let's
so let's start off with this I'm a big
Star Wars junkie so in case you guys
seen a lot of things really so it's not
that it's on like business endorsing me
realizes that I like Star Wars stuff so
here's an example where for example we
get all this information based on this
image like it's Lego it's Star Wars it's
it says Lego Star Wars it's information
about the product and if you go back to
the prior image where we talked about
the and back so let me go back to that
scenario so yours another example where
in this case it's a mug again I'm a huge
Star Wars junkie so in case you're
wondering why all my products are all at
some relation Star Wars just because
drug wants an awesome movie I think I'm
not wired on the Internet
so I think you guys
yeah
perfect thank you so let's let's go back
and start this again so for example in
the in the image that I just showed you
earlier in the things in this case we
actually it brings up a letter bag and
we can find we can give you use Amalia
that would give you and this is the
other additional method you get from the
web and so you can you can imagine how
you can start using this method right
the scenarios again I just want to
reiterate for the web metadata really
depends if a similar image exists on the
web so if it's if it's an object that's
not present on the external web you most
probably will not get any metadata on it
I talked a lot of our products but are
also other cases where people are
thinking about furniture shopping people
are thinking about other scenarios and
there's a couple of examples of that so
in this case you know I pinned up
grabbed a bunch of images from for
example you have a for potentially a
furniture store people are coming on
loading images they want to find similar
stuff and you can imagine where you get
metadata on on those pieces or the box
we give you additional metadata you can
now use to drive potential additional
searches downstream I'll just do one
more image and then I'll go back to the
road one
so in the in the key aspect this year of
example we recognize it's road one Star
Wars Jan or so etc based on this cup and
this is a cup and then the other piece
that we also give you is information
where else is this image exist you can
imagine we give you the additional
information of all the stores where this
image shows up at so that's another
special piece we think about a market
place people have uploaded a bunch of
images you guys wanted a quick fraud
check to see if you see images of stock
images or they come from a valid place
you can very easily run those images
through the API and see visa valid
images or not and then use the
subsequent metadata to drive searches
back to slides
so let's want the next use case we're
talking about recommendation so in the
case of recommendation there's a lot of
different scenarios that we want to talk
about it really you can think about it
drives a lot of different scenarios all
the way from thinking about how you to
write write content in YouTube they're
thinking about how you can drag the
appropriate cross-sell or upsell for the
customer but as I mentioned there's a
lot of different facts of the drive into
the recommendation aspect so you really
want to think about how does the watch
the history of the user behavior what
does it user being doing on your site or
what purchases that it done with your
store prior to that what's the current
product metadata that's really where if
you can imagine if your product is more
of a physical device your product is
more of a soft device whether it's a
video with a piece of content you really
want to get that metadata so you can
drive things downstream or on
recommendation models and Rajiv's going
to talk a little bit about some of the
models that enabled us we provide you a
rich platform to enable that and so
right now what we use is sense of slope
so then really when you think about
machine learning that there is a
pipeline for that there's a pipeline for
really thinking about training how do
you think about training this a model
but you take your data the data can say
data in GCS in the in in Google Cloud
storage you feed it through a data flow
pipeline to process the data to get the
right features that you want then you
try then you get a tensile flow models
that you have gone through training that
you look at the model parameters tweak
it appropriately and then the model goes
to the production which then then drive
downstream processes right so this is
really where tensor flow and things like
cloud ml engine comes into play to
really drive this end-to-end models and
but then you can then you can imagine
the pipeline doesn't just fit with
machine learning the pipeline is enter
and the pipeline goes with all the way
from how you think about your log data
you click screen behavior coming in from
with its cloud pub/sub but it's metadata
flowing through things like cloud
storage and all there and the end result
is really thinking about all your
analysts who have to do things around
hey help me understand my prior history
my sales behavior my purchase history
and thinking about how to then figure
out all the BI and data and data Wells
is stuff that's been going on for 10 15
years all those things does not go away
with machine learning I think if you
imagine you need that to drive machine
learn if you don't have that you can
have to go back and fix your bi and data
warehouses because without data there is
no ml
right so Jody secret of a machine
learning is 90% of the work is getting
your data into your data where else
cleanse process you can drive downstream
machine learning processes so we
shouldn't forget that piece if I could
think of it as a tip of the spear right
you need it's a shiny part but it's a
lot of work that happens to get that
data to the model for training so this
kind of scenario kind of talks to you
about in to and pipeline not just from
how do we feed data whether it's think
about clickstream behavior these are
lots of events that go across all your
servers feeding through a cloud pub/sub
pipelines that integrative a data flow
that does the processing it then dumps
your data into bigquery but your analyst
most of all you're going to run a bunch
of queries and analysis on that with
your favorite bi tool but it's tableau
and then once you've kind of done your
data processing what I call the data
janitorial work where you figure out
what's the right data what's the right
features you didn't do subsequent
processing feed that into a format
that's compatible with tensorflow create
your cloud machine learning model create
a tensor flow model and then you do some
appropriate level of evaluation then put
it in production most often not directly
in production you will have to do things
like an a/b test process you figure out
which is the right model am I getting
the results I want in actual production
before you roll it out right that's down
there's a lot of processes that happen
before a data user behavior data goes to
an actual ml model what I want to charge
and it off to Rajeev to talk about how
someone actually did this in production
and Raj ikan is going to walk
a use case where you help the customer
walk through the scenario internet
thanks Ron juggling lots of devices and
I hope all of them work okay with Wi-Fi
in the screen resolution okay so so I do
machine learning stuff at PwC and we do
a lot of the dirty work that Graham was
talking about taking data taking
historic data and we see across our
clients we see some kinds of a lot of
data but they have security issues about
what can be used what cannot be use some
kinds don't have data and sometimes you
don't know what type of data they have
and we take that data and we figure out
how to put it in the right context and
we've built several training models on
tensorflow
and I'll talk about one of them which is
for a company called sky which is a
large television package provider in
Mexico it's kind of like a verizon or
AT&T of Mexico you can go to the thing
so the challenge here is that they
literally have door-to-door salesmen who
go and try to sell you different
television packages and over the years
they've got lots of sales data but they
lots of sales data in terms of what
television package was sold to which
area but they don't have any data and
time in knowing you know which type of
people are interested in sports packages
which type of people are interested in
HBO who wants to watch reality TV or
anything like that so what we created
for them is we built simple tablet
applications retail kiosks skype retail
kiosks for them so users can interact
with these kiosks in a fun way and they
can just pick a few movies or TV shows
that they like and based on that the
machine learning code figures out what
type of television package or and what
kind of hardware along with that that
person would be best suited for this is
a problem there you have to try and
figure out what a user wants with very
little data in other sessions we've
spoken about what to do with a lot of
data so and we built this on cloud
platform essentially what we have is the
kiosk screen and there's all the app
code is driven on App Engine and we
basically have the input data coming
when a user selects different TV shows
that he or she likes and that goes into
a noodle a single layered neural network
that we've built and deployed on
tensorflow and I'll show you some
screens and graphs from that as well and
based on that the tensorflow figures out
what product should be recommended for
that person essentially the math
challenge here is how do you do
good filtering for a user without having
a lot of data about that user there's a
lot of different types of filtering you
can do essentially I mean they all have
fancy names but basically it comes down
to we want to filter stuff based on what
this user has done in the past or based
on if if I like to watch HBO somebody
else likes to watch HBO and that
somebody else also likes to watch Comedy
Central then what's the likelihood I
would like to watch Comedy Central so
and there's different types of filtering
techniques like that we've picked a
collaborative filtering technique here
what it basically means is if you have
all your users on one axis and you've
all your shows or TV packages on the
other axis you have some data for users
for some of the packages and you have
holes in places and so the whole
mathematical challenge is how do you
fill the holes how do you know that if I
pick a B and C then what's the
likelihood I'd be interested in B as
well and the reason we use canceled flow
for this is our initial training data
has something like 20,000 you
and on the other axis we had some data
for these users on about 300 different
types of TV channels so essentially it
was like a twenty thousand by three
hundred matrix that we were executing
but that pretty soon exploded into
having over two million users and
something like twenty thousand data
points and so that becomes a very hard
computational problem and that's where
you can just you can you can easily
tweak your models in tensorflow to scale
with the amount of data that you get so
I'll try to show you some of these
things you know which one to plug into
the tablet can I have the tablet screen
please there you go it's going to be a
little psychedelic because for some
reason I can't get it to work in the
other resolution but think of this as
your afternoon neck exercise but you
could also drop by at the PWC booth and
it works in a less psychedelic way there
so let's tap on this we call this the TV
show gobbler so it first has a little
image recognition thing it recognizes me
but I always make this joke that all
machine learning it the the goal is to
detect Indian names properly and it
still detects Rajiv as ratchet but we'll
go with that for now let's play okay so
imagine this is a kiosk and it shows you
a bunch of TV shows and you select a
bunch of things that you like and it's
going to try to figure out what your
interests are based on this definitely
halt and catch fire
Westworld and if you see the bottom tab
it already detected from a very little
amount of data I detected what I like
obviously the more number of things that
I pick gotta pick the liar the more
number things that you fix the more it
learns about you and so let's see what
it kind of figured out about me so it
figures out a bunch of interest tags a
bunch of things based on facial
recognition it tries to estimate my age
and then it looks at you know I've liked
the show halt and catch fire how many
other people have liked it in that age
demographic how many people like it and
it executes that tensor computation I'll
show you that and based on that it
selects these different the the ones
which are white are not things that are
for me and the ones that are in color
are what the algorithm things I'd be
interested in I'm so happy it didn't
pick reality-tv infirm follow you so
let's see what it recommends based on
that so based on this know our customers
sky can't figure out what type of bundle
of TV package they can sell to me and
and these bundles have different
channels and there's a certain price I
was certain amount of hardware with it
and if I select one of these bundles and
then you can have other related products
to it and this also has image
recognition where if I place a product
in front of it it'll detect the product
it's trying to do it right now but I
don't have a product to place in front
of it but any products whether it's a
bar code that it could have or a product
you know you put a Google home or a
daydream or something in front of it
it'll pick it up it will find the right
price it'll allow you to add it to your
queue contact the sales reps all kinds
of things today so if you come over to
the PWC kiosk at some point we'll show
you all these things in a better
resolution if I can have the laptop
again please can I set link for the
tensor board okay could we move to the
demo box quick so I'm not sure how how
many of you know a lot about this and
are going to grill me about it
how many of you don't know much at all
about tensorflow so I'll briefly go over
some things
so essentially
tensorflow is a computation engine right
and you give it some model and it's
going to execute it for you and how you
design that models which in this case
happens to be a single layer noodle
network and when you feed it so you see
this thing called the softmax here so
that's kind of the function that that we
use and that decides kind of the bias
and the weight so if you think about all
the users on one axis and all the
interests on another axis let's say
hypothetically it's a twenty thousand by
two hundred matrix right so that's N and
out of that that that's my input tensor
and that has to give me an output that
tells me for each of these twenty
thousand users which one of the ten
television packages they can sell to me
so the twenty thousand by two hundred
input training tensor should give me an
output of twenty thousand by by ten
essentially and that's what and to do
that essentially you have to do some
kind of if you were to do it without
something like sensor flow you sit and
compute different permutations and
combinations of the weights that you
have to put into this and the bias that
you have to print
the beauty of cancer flow is that it
allows you to define a function and play
with the bias in the wave in graphic
time till you can get your model to a
level there your input model to a level
there it looks like you're getting the
right output from the training from the
training set so when you do that when
you have that model and then if you look
at the distribution it's essentially
over time it has to kind of converge so
you know that the bias that you've given
or the weights that you put into your
weighted algorithm it's kind of coming
to a sort of a convergence so you know
how good or bad your training model is
and I'll show you one last thing maybe
so if you're doing anything with
tensorflow
and you know you've always got somebody
yelling at your saying how do I know how
good or bad this is how do I know how
accurate this is and you kind of have to
look at a loss curve over time to kind
of say hey you know it has to go down a
little bit over time even if it doesn't
go down this much if it's not going down
and that loss curve is not reducing then
the the variance is too high and you to
go back and kind of tweak your model
some more so I just want to show you a
couple screens and intensive flow makes
it really easy to do those things on
tensor board and execute the functions
and on tensor flow instead of having to
kind of go through lots of permutations
of iterations for those input functions
so that's what we did with one of our
coins guy and I'll give it back to round
so that was a quick aspect of so again
going back to the story when I talk
about help you help customers find the
right product then second aspect is help
from your perspective recommender rights
and relevant product at the right time
and then the third piece that we want to
talk about a little bit about how do we
go back to understanding product
reception right how do we think about
what's going on in the field how is this
father getting receive what a customer
is talking about it how do you
understand product reviews etc and
that's really what I wanted to spend
sometimes the rest of the third scenario
and talk a little bit about how we can
really focus on natural language
understanding that's really going to be
law just to noise I'm going to talk
about that but there's a lot of other
pieces that goes into kind of getting
product reception this pork is that you
can imagine aspects where you think
about reference for your product there
are other pieces like if you start
thinking about social media and you
think about the images that flowed
through social media and you want to
start associating hey how's my product
like logo perceived in social media what
are people doing normally with my
product that's another aspect that we
can think about logo detection and image
processing to enable those scenarios but
the other piece is I think a lot more I
would say fundamentalist product reviews
right you guys as product reviews galore
there are things that people are talking
about on social media what are people
saying about my products there are
product reviews coming from magazines
from publishers find my products tell me
what's going on tell me what's relevant
for my product what else are they
talking about and the others did the
other aspects is when you think about we
look at a review things that you want
understand reviews what entities they're
covering in my review right work for
example when they talk about our product
what other product are they talking
about what are the competitors are they
talking about what else do they
associate my products with that's really
thing I just talked about for example
suggest phones I think for example if
I'm selling a new model phone what else
do people normally think of a next talk
about my phone and the third part is
what the sentiment was a positive or
negative so you can then drive those
pieces for the downstream pieces you can
see can imagine are things like a were
the most impulsive integers of features
or the most negative features etc to
drive product reception there are lots
of other pieces that come into this we
can imagine product telemetry if you
rate probably electronic products the
kiosk
like to drive future product planning
but in this piece is what I'm going to
be talking about really around how can
we use language understanding to see
what the external world is talking about
you so if you switch back to the demo so
the thing I'm going to focus on is the
Nexus 6p so basically I'm going to start
off with Nexus 6p and say you know your
is a product review it's a I pick the
site it's not trusted reviews and it
focus a little aspects of how this phone
is received and what I'm going to do
with that is actually use that product
review in the context of our natural
language API so a natural language API
offers things like named entity
recognition recognized the most relevant
entities in a block of text so it finds
things like our own organization and
find things like people they find things
like consumer goods or the box and most
common nouns today primarily where these
entities are normally linked to a URL in
Wikipedia so we find if it's an entity
that's in Wikipedia most probably will
pick it up from a natural language API
so let me go ahead and grab this piece
of text I hate doing a live demo
sometimes because I actually copied it
but then my side and you know mechanical
problems
so let's go analyze it so one of the
things that that I wanted to show that
is the first thing it picks up is it if
you look at this concept called salience
so the first thing is it's scan to the
article and picked up this article is
really about the Nexus 6p right that's
the first thing you really want to sign
you're going to get a lot of lot of text
coming into your organization what is
this article about so that's the first
thing it's very finds out about the
other thing you want to think about
these things that's really focus one of
the key value points that Google roll
you want to land
what's premium right that's really we
focus on next six XP as really as a
premium premium consumer mobile device
and it's a good thing is this the
article actually brought that up into
flow the other aspects is we want to
talk about is is other pieces around
design salient other pieces that are
there other consumer goods are that's
normally referred to with Nexus 6p in
this case for example we pick up the
fact that people also talk about Samsung
Galaxy s7 in the same article so you can
imagine those are pretty chemical
substitutes from a customer perspective
think about how do we bring those two
products together let me do another
example in this case I brought up the
pixel see
I'm going to go ahead and copy that
piece of texture
so in this piece again the two key
pieces that you want to think about is
that so what do we want understand you
understand what is this article about
second thing one understand is what
other organizations normally is referred
to when we talk about this product we
could bring up aspects like Samsung we
think about the products that goes with
that and then the other thing that I
want to also start thinking about is is
this about a tablet we figure out the
consumer good or the box you can imagine
we start speaking up salient entities or
this so the speech that I also wanted
then drive is the next piece I want to
talk about is how do we think about a
sentiment of the saw of this article so
I'm going to break up an article but
Google owned
sorry
I know I know watching me copy text is
not the most fun thing to do
so a couple of things in this case so
that what we've done is look at the
sentiment analysis on an actual using
our natural language API so basically
natural language API when you take a
block of text you run into ENL API you
get to kind of scores on that you get a
document sentiment and the two pieces
you get is whether the score from minus
one to plus one minus one be negative
plus one being positive and then the
magnitude of how positive that article
was in this case you would think this
audio is actually moderately pretty
positive and then you can then and then
give you things like document sentiment
it kind of walks you through how the
article is so kind of flows so as you
guys are start thinking about taking
this block of text if you think about
product reviews coming in you want to
start scanning all these articles start
figuring out which articles refers to my
product and to is as you said and then
you want second thing you want start
thinking about this are these articles
positive or negative on my products and
the third part I will not and I'm not
covering today's you can also imagine
that you want to start looking at which
features are positive and which features
are negative and at some part we're not
going to cover so in the end what what
well what can you do with that so you
can imagine things like relationship
graphs right so your what we've done is
we basically ran every Wikipedia article
through our named entity recognition and
we basically started mapping a
relationship graph based on which
entities are common together in an
article so this line basically shows if
there a lot of articles read for example
Nexus 6p and Motorola show up in the
same article it's a thicker line and a
shorter line and the case for example
Nexus 6p and Sony we're running a few
articles with the right level things a
much longer line and thinner line so
really say it's okay kind of a very
crude form of a relationship graph you
can now thinking about how do these all
these products fit together what's the
relationship with the product you can
even imagine you can start adding
sentimental deadlines say a dissenter
values normally cause strong sentiments
positive sentiments based on reviews so
you can get a better feel as you start
looking at from a product perspective
from a sales perspective how these the
relationships drive certain behavior
that make sense and of course that's
grace more product perspective but what
I want to end with is something that's
more important something for
with Simon Lannister related to in Game
of Thrones because I'm a big Game of
Thrones fan you can magic and do
something similar for Game of Thrones
thing and you can see right now the time
and Lannister is connected tightly on
line up there even though it should be a
much stronger relationship as you guys
only if you're a Game of Thrones fans
not that many so just jokes just went
right over your head alright so coming
back slides please
so well so what we've been through right
now is again can we try circling back
what we talked about we talked about the
three key scenarios a mission on you can
enable one is how do we find the right
product right how do we enable do we
provide a more intelligent search
process within retail sites thinking
about image metadata primarily in this
case is search by image the second
things we talked about is recommendation
and we and Reggie walk through a
scenario but how do we enable customers
to recommend the right go do you
recommend all you enable sales folks to
recommend the right products or
customers the third part we just talked
abouts understanding feedback based on
products and understand how are people
talking about your product what else are
they talking about you can start
building relationship graphs without
poker level of sentiment so that's
really what I wanted to cover in this
session I want to leave time for more
questions for you guys for the next 10
minutes or so there are lots of other
chef sessions are covered good deep more
into a machine learning some of them may
already be done so we when we did this
slide you can make a lot of sessions
happen before I think this one tomorrow
around the data lifecycle which I highly
recommend also and those things are on
how to use sensor flow with a lot of the
things that
Rajiv talked about that's a good session
or on how do you do tend to flow and
solve them or without a PhD you need I
think those videos are up on YouTube so
those are sessions that if you guys
really more interest intensive loud as
you recommend somewhere your aspect
around MLA P is we have a session that
covers basically how we do all the
different ML SIA api scan it does a walk
through the Sarah Robinson did earlier
today those videos are also up on
YouTube so with that Rajeev I like to
invite Rajeev up and open the door to
questions
[Applause]
[Music]
you